like my Hardy here the game spot news
update recently the founders of
criterion games sees the possibility of
a spiritual successor to the burnout
series also I love the smell of my own
farts who wrote this three field
entertainment a studio founded last year
by criterion founders Alex Ward and
Fiona Sperry sent out tweets this week
that sound promising for burnout fans
the first tweet reads two things our
first game is a multiplayer sports game
coming spring 2016 then we make a
driving game the second tweet referring
to the burnout series reads what sort of
driving game you ask a spiritual
successor speed traffic and crashing
lots and lots of crashing the various
entries in the burnout series of which
there are four main games were fairly
different from each other this raises
the question of which game this new one
would follow in the footsteps of three
fields itself seems uncertain a final
tweet reads spiritual successor to which
one though the second the third or the
fourth one in 2009 criterion shifted
from working on burnout to take over the
need for Speed series in 2013 most of
criterion staff was moved over to go
schemes to continue focusing on need for
speed leaving criterion with a
relatively low head count wardens fairy
left the studio not long after so here's
hoping it's a spiritual successor to
burn out 3 take down more news stay
tuned to gamespot com you can also read
more of Mike McCarty shitty writing god
damn it Mary
you